(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Загалом поясню спершу, що збудуть представляти такі зустрічі.
Як ви бачили, вони були зазначені до кінця
цього семестру, тобто по кожній середі.
Сергій Олексійович, скоріше за все, брати участь в
них не буде, залежить від познання в цісті,
але хоча б сьогоднішній він брати участь не
буде.
Загалом основна ідея в тому, щоб записувати проміжні
результати, тобто ідентифікувати, якщо є якісь проблеми у
вас, якщо є якісь незрозумілості стосовно того, що
треба робити, якщо немає, наприклад, деякі люди просто
позникали і не встигаєте доробити проєкт.
Тобто будь-які проблеми, які виникають під час
розробки проєкту чи виконання будь-яких завдань, ви
можете їх задавати.
Тобто фактично як консультація, але називається як стендап.
Тому загалом перше питання, яке є незрозумілості стосовно
того, що потрібно буде зробити на п'ятницю,
спробувати хоча б оглянути в Асані.
Чи були якісь проблеми?
Ми, в принципі, складно розуміємо, що нам треба
робити.
Ми зрозуміли, що треба робити в Асані.
Але саме які зараз стоять перед нами задачі
на п'ятницю, таке собі.
Добре.
Задачі на п'ятницю.
Як ви перша команда, хоча б іншою.
Я зараз також обговорю.
Бачу, Олександр є.
Дивіться, вам вибрали проєкт.
Мені здається, у вас був блог.
Чи я не помиляюсь?
Так, у вас був блог.
Тобто, що вам треба зробити?
Загалом ви можете не створювати поки завдання в
Асані конкретно, але вам треба обговорити, що ви
хочете розробити як команду.
Тобто, писати приблизників і дизайн хочете його.
Можете взяти якісь приклади, можливо, спростіше буде це.
Можливо, в інтересі можна шукати, що там є.
І подивитись загалом приклади, можливо, інших блогів.
Тобто, що ви хотіли розробити.
І, базуючись на цьому, зробити якийсь базовий список
пунктів, які ваш блог має робити.
Тобто, з базового це, мабуть, якщо ви хочете
адмін-панель, який ви додаєте функціонал, наприклад, як
додавати нові записи, видаляти записи і якось їх
коригувати.
Тобто, це основна перша задача, спробувати загалом придумати
проєкт.
Коротко про те, що ми будемо робити в
п'ятницю.
Це все ж таки, тому що, напевно, ми
говорили, що воно більш відне заняття.
Тобто, ми не починали спринг, ми не починали
якісь конкретні завдання.
В п'ятницю ми якраз таки будемо намагатися
з того, які у вас є побажання до
проєкту.
І я буду загалом допомагати спорювати завдання.
І ми будемо організовувати роботу, яку вже вам
потім через тиждень, вам її доведеться вже виконувати
якусь і робити.
Так як в п'ятницю у нас лише
лабораторне завдання, наскільки я пам'ятаю, практичне завдання
на 9.30. Тобто, п'ятницю ми будемо
намагатися розбиратись з цим.
Тобто, почати спринт, я креслю, що потрібно буде
зробити, ми загалом обговоримо, яку реально роботу можна
виконати за той період.
Тобто, декілька завдань, зробити щось базове, це новий
айсблог за один тиждень, але трошки по невеличких
частинах ітеративно його робити.
Тобто, це загалом те, що бажано було б
зробити, хоча б загальну ідею блогу, щоб розуміти,
що створювати в п'ятниці.
Загалом так, але ми можемо це організувати в
п'ятницю.
Сергій Олексійович, знову ж таки, я не впевнений.
Він має бути в п'ятниці, я дуже
сподіваюся.
Але якщо не буде, то я, можливо, як.
Тому що ми розділили ролі в тому, що
Сергій Олексійович, все ж таки, він як стейкхолер,
а тобто клієнт іде, і я як продуктовенер,
а тобто власник продукту.
Я можу давати завдання також, звісно, замість Сергія
Олексійовича, але Сергій Олексійович в основному буде їх
оцінювати.
Тобто, з мого боку, я допомагати буду вам
робити, створювати завдання в АСАНі, можливо, їх пріоритізувати,
допомога якась технічна.
Тобто, в цих аспектах так.
Стосовно проєкту, знову ж таки, тут все можна
скоригувати.
Тобто, до п'ятниці ви можете дати загальну
картину того, що ви хотіли б бачити в
блогі.
І, знову ж таки, оцінюючи реалістично те, що
ви можете зробити до кінця семестру за 8
занять іще додатково.
І, базуючись на цьому, розробити.
Тобто, це має бути основна вимога, що це
має бути вебдодаток.
І далі, базуючись на цьому, вже будемо виходити.
Тобто, якщо це вебдодаток, використовуючи вебтехнології, вже з
цього можна буде розробляти і далі коригувати завдання.
Ага, окей.
Дивіться.
Є така ще невеличка проблемка.
Типу, снаукуватися, я так розумію, із нашої команди
буду я.
Але я не певна, що в мене вийде
змога бути в п'ятницю.
Як ви дивитесь на те, щоб я просто
підготувала питання вам з приводу цього?
Ну, типу, вже там більш конкретизували.
Я думаю, що одногрупники висловляють свою думку з
приводу того, що ми там зараз напишемо і
які у нас там будуть ідеї з приводу
блога.
А ви просто несте відповіді.
Я їду просто завтра на конференцію, на тренінг
для вчителів.
У мене трошки не буде змоги бути присутньою
на занятті.
Звісно, без проблем.
Тут немає вимоги, щоб бути обов'язково там.
Можете передати, можете написати в чаті команди.
Тут без різниці буде запис заняття, тому можете
переглянути, або знову ж таки передати через колег.
Тут загалом це спрацює.
Головне, щоб підготувати загальну ідею проєкту.
Добре, я зрозуміла, тоді дякую.
Чи є якісь питання з першої команди, можливо,
ще?
Напевно, з нашої команди все, але от у
нас ще є одногрупники.
От, наприклад, Саша Харченко, як я вже казала,
можливо, він там буде з нашими колегами, які
зараз за кордоном.
Я точно не знаю, це так мої були
припущення.
То, ну, я думаю, що також треба їй
може конкретно дати якісь завдання зараз.
Так, Олександр, тоді хотів запитати, чи була можливість
скоординуватися з нагрупниками, з якими можливо було б
команду створити, які брали участь?
Так, ми вже скоординувалися, ми вже пропустили, може,
якийсь самий план у нас буде.
Але суть наша незрозуміла в тому, що у
нас ж немає теми, і ми не змогли
знайти її.
Так, дивіться, стосовно теми, загалом, зараз я знайду,
є вже готові теми, було, так, секунду, десь
вони мене дали.
Ось вони.
Загалом є п'ять тем як пропозиція того,
що можна зробити.
У нас є відправи в чат.
Тобто це за стосунок для управління завданнями, чисті
поасани або джера, простий каталог електронної комерції, якоїсь
роду магазин з продажу чогось, погодний інформер з
використанням зовнішніх API, тобто там є публічна купа
API, які можна просто викликати, і вони, загалом,
повертають цю інформацію.
Там далі більше питання в тому, щоб це
все гарно оформити.
Система особистого блогу, загалом те, що брала перша
команда, і за стосунок для збору рецептів.
Немає якихось досить жорстких вимог.
Тобто ви можете обговорити те, що ви хочете.
Єдина вимога – це те, що це має
бути веб-проект.
Тобто будь-який веб-сайт, який ви хочете
розробити, можливо, з тих тематик, які я скину,
можливо, з тематик, які ви побажаєте.
Як я і пояснював в першій команді, потрібно,
щоб вписувалось в 2-місячний період, який ви
будете розробляти.
Тобто ще 8 тижнів активної дезміну з розробки
до кінця семестри.
А там, якщо ваша команда хоче розробити щось
інше, то цілком.
Так, ще з'явилося одне питання.
Простий каталог електронної комерції.
Це що може означати?
Тобто це інтернет-магазин?
Так, тут в цілому можна щось і простеньке
зробити.
Або магазин якийсь, чий-то магазин одягу, з
базовим інтерфейсом, якому це буде декілька стрінок, тобто
стрінка з каталогом.
Можливо, як додавати туди якийсь адмінфонет, чи додавати
нові позиції.
Тобто щось таке простеньке.
Дуже невеличкий сайт, який можна буде робити загалом
несправжні замови.
Інтеграції не потрібно робити.
Ага, зрозумію.
Тоді ми вже, як би сказали, пройшли початковий
етап, створили стрінку з головною стрінкою, каталогом, і
ще, мабуть, хотіли б додати кнопки з реєстрацією
та замовленням.
Так, цілком можна.
Дивіться, давайте я вас зараз тоді, поки в
нас є можливість, додам до проєкту Васані.
Можливо, можете скинути ваш емейл і колеги, які
будуть з вами разом працювати, щоб я вас
додав до загального команду, де ви будете розробляти.
І в п'ятниці, загалом до п'ятниці,
ви так само можете згуртуватись і придумати більш
-менш те, що ви хотіли розробляти.
Це не має бути все, але загальна ідея
того, що хотілося би розробити, і далі ми
вже будемо виходити і розробляти якісь базові завдання.
Ага, зрозуміло.
Дякую.
Так, зараз я...
В мене десь ваші емейли були.
Так, один емейл знайшов.
Олександр, можете, будь ласка, скинути емейли ваших колег,
з якими будете працювати в чат, якщо можливо,
звісно.
Так, і запрошення, і вам також відправо.
Тоді, мабуть, треба створити групу в Телеграмі.
Так, покликання на групу в Телеграмі я вже
зробив.
Сьогодні зранку я її зробив.
Ага, бачу.
Як це, я із закордоном, одногрупники.
Зрозуміло.
Так, я зараз додам ще Сергія Олексійовича.
Так, є.
І стосовно емейлів двох інших, Богдана, як я
розумію, і іншого, не розумію, Олексія, є у
вас їхні емейли?
А це твій європейець.
Я йому скажу, щоб нормально переименувався.
Так.
Тому що емейли я їх не...
В мене є список ваш загальний, але...
Може бути трохи застарілим.
Добре, тоді, якщо буде можливо, запитайте в них,
хай вони скинуть емейли, хоча б сьогодні було
б добре.
Чи в дивчат, можливо.
Я їх додам до проєкту.
У вас я вже додав.
От, іпільськ, детально.
Потім все, ми попрацюємо тоді в п'ятницю.
Та і загалом, я думаю, чи є у
вас ще якісь загалом питання?
Першої чи другої команди?
Немає.
Добре.
Ні, немає.
Тоді...